oh plan time to chill
welcome welcome to the corridor crew
channel
you've caught me recovering from a epic
adventure my backpack was really heavy
and my back hurts now so i'm stretching
my neck
and my back and it's just not deep
enough i need to go deeper it's super
easy for all of us to burn out to go a
week upon week after week after week of
making videos living life taking care of
family hanging out with friends it's
very it's a very fast life keep that up
for too long and something's gonna
happen explode into a fiery bits or you
know your anger will come out onto your
friends and to your wife your girlfriend
your boyfriend whoever you wouldn't know
i mean maybe you would know
i don't know get upset it's wrong um
my my stress and anxiety will come out
onto friends my girlfriend
my stress will kind of carry over into
friendships or relationships and that's
that's not cool so how do you take care
of that for me personally it is to take
breaks and to meditate to slow down to
go for a walk
talking about dropping what you're doing
and going on an epic adventure my good
friend tyler he's the guy who called me
up and was like hey clint you want to
build a tank and i was like uh yeah it
took us a year to build a tank out of
cardboard it's always random when tyler
calls me because he asks me some
ridiculous questions
such as do you want to climb a volcano
in like a week i'm down for anything i'm
down to go on to any adventure get in
trouble a little bit let's just do it
and then if you get in trouble just be
like i'm sorry
yes this will be my second volcano
the first one in indonesia was for a
yoga trip for like nine days to just do
yoga it was with a group of people i've
never done anything like this before i
didn't know what to expect never been to
bali they were like alright guys we're
doing a volcano hike three in the
morning it was a sunrise hike all of the
like dirt and sand it was just like
ash and every step you take you're
sliding down another step so you gotta
take big steps it's an intense hike hey
beautiful sunrise there were monkeys up
there yeah yeah but they would steal
your food they stole my freaking pancake
they stole my bananas um but they were
cute little guys oh great great little
guys so that was my first
hold on i gotta switch sides oh man it's
a deep stretch
oh that's that that's that left oh
that's the left side that's the left
side stretch
don't get mad when your body stops
wanting to work because it only makes it
worse it only makes it harder and the
best thing you can do is keep moving
forward except this is what you're in
this is the state you're in and there's
no way out and you put yourself here and
you got to keep going forward and be
okay with it if you can control your
mental state in those times of
difficulty in those times when you like
you want to give up that's like the
ultimate challenge for me for me
personally we're fortunate enough to
have be given vacation time yeah if you
don't have that uh that luxury like you
still need to check out right yeah
what if you're like your job is at stake
can you do that
is it worth it
that's super tough what what's the worst
thing that ever happened to you from
forgetting a password i was locked out
of paypal accepting like freelance jobs
and i couldn't get paid because they
shut down my paypal and like locked it
up password was wrong or something i
tried again it was like the security
security questions are the worst yeah
dude it's like what was your pet's name
the sponsor of today's episode is
lastpass the leading online password
manager already used by millions
encrypts all your passwords with a
master password that only you know you
don't have to write it down or hide it
in a wall you don't have to get locked
out of your bank account and not be able
to use it you just need to keep that one
password in your head
and that's it oh i've been thinking
about getting that have you yeah
and now we're sponsored
eddie in the wild you've been thinking
about getting it yeah
they they store your passwords right and
you only have to remember one password
to get into that one well it will
automatically log you into things yes
it's a chrome
extension oh it's the next oh i got you
so all you do is you use the extension
and then if the extension's on and
you're logged into it on that browser
you go to facebook it'll be on your
account so i can have it home i can have
it here can i have it on my phone yeah
of course you've lost two hundred
dollars from for getting a password yeah
okay explain
that
when nico and i went to new york we met
with sean and peter mckinnon and we all
won those xboxes came back and uh nick
and i wanted to play some zombie games
on xbox but i had to sign up to get that
microsoft live account and i forgot
about how you can't recover anything if
you forget something i forgot my
password so i try to sign in and they're
like oh you can't sign it was like okay
how can i recover well i'll try to
change the password well you have to go
through the submission form to change
your password i get an email saying we
don't have enough evidence to prove that
this account belongs to you
has been going on for months and each
month each month is ten dollars
ten bucks a month yeah i've called
microsoft
if you use lastpass it'll keep all your
passwords in a password vault and it
will encrypt them all
so that it's all messy and only you on
your end have the code to decrypt it and
then you just use a master pass for
everything
since i've come up with a similar
solution
i have a notebook hidden in my wall
that has that that has every password
every username to every single account
that i have ever made
let me get this straight the way that
you deal with this
is by taking a pen and paper writing
them all down on a notebook and hiding
it in your inside of your walls what if
a mouse goes in there i got cats
what if the apartment catches fire
through their master password system and
encryption algorithm lastpass relieves
the trouble of getting locked out of
accounts and the anxiety that comes with
that so it keeps you sane you don't have
to write remember or reset passwords
real real simple so if you guys are
interested in signing up for lastpass
just go on down click the link in the
description and tell them corridor
digital sent yeah
talk to your boss be like yo i've been
here putting in my hours working hard i
want to be
working my best for you and i feel like
i'm burning i feel like i'm needing a
vacation did you understand you can't
expect someone to sprint forever just be
like i'm doing this for you i'm telling
you not really gotta take a break take
two weeks go with your family go with
your friends go with your girlfriend go
with your boyfriend go alone go go alone
traveling
can be expensive plane tickets hotels i
like airbnb but what i do honestly i
just take a chunk of my paycheck put it
into travel savings and you save up for
travel so that way you're not killing
yourself when you pull out that travel
money traveling taking breaks are as
important as your diet like your mental
health is just as important as your
physical health let's talk about how was
the the hike up that volcano with tyler
just the essentials in my backpack water
snacks the first part was like shady
forest
everywhere there were mosquitoes
i hate mosquitoes for about two
miles two and a half miles we're seeing
a deer run around giant evergreen trees
and then we finally come out to this
like little like plateau area where you
saw
the volcano way in the background wait
way over there
changing out some film
just finished my black and white roll
now i'm on to velvia 50.
there's anything worth taking a picture
of up here probably not i mean
i was going to take a picture of my
phone get a nice
plains rolling hills
you look down into this valley and
there's like a lake and then in the
distance there's this huge like zelda
mountain over here it was incredible it
smelled like christmas it smelled like
very crisp fresh air and we get to
a checkpoint and then we start seeing
snow where there's lake and then there's
a glacier up it looks like we're almost
there but we got like another two hours
to go we chilled out there eat a couple
apples and clif bars and have some
coffee and chill out
it was beautiful we chilled our
champagne in the ice
because of course we got to bring
champagne for the top and then we hiked
across this like snow field
we packed up we head across this like
this ice
valley climb up to the very top and
there's this breathtaking view
all right dude where are we going
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so yeah slow down plan time to chill
even when you're chilling all right i
gotta do 30 push-ups i challenge all of
you go on an adventure of some sort this
year whether it be a weekend trip a week
long trip or a two-week long trip go on
an adventure absorb the area around you
be there be in that moment drop your
responsibilities forget about instagram
if you can i know it's tough come back
write about it go back through all your
pictures really really just enjoy it you
know enjoy enjoy that vacation and then
send us some pictures or tweet at us
instagram at us however you gotta get at
us send us a message and let us know
what you did what you learned what you
felt and if you're going to go on a
vacation again
oh
was that good that was great okay
i got stung to my pants dude
it's perfect let's let's go out oh hey
man we gotta go we gotta go
we can fix it